[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SATURDAY NIGHT AND DONALD TRUMP
HAS MORE BALLS IN THE AIR THAN A
JUGGLING NUDIST.
[LAUGHTER]
HE'S GOT NORTH KOREA THE
MIDTERMS, MS
MIDTERMS, MS 13 AND SPEAKING OF
THOSE FINE CHAPS LET'S BEGIN
WITH A QUIZ.
ANIMUS 13 DOG GOT SENTENCED TO
40 YEARS IN JAIL FOR CRIMES
INVOLVING THE MURDER OF A
TEENAGER.
QUICK QUESTION.
WHAT WAS HIS GANG NICKNAME?
>> ANIMAL.
GREG: IMAGINE THAT.
IT WASN'T CUDDLES OR CAPTAIN
SNUGGLE US ANY WONDER WHY HIS
NUMBERS KEEP RISING LIKE CHRIS
MATTHEWS BLOOD PRESSURE BECAUSE
HE IS RIGHT.
HE IS TARGETING ANIMALS AND THEY
ARE PARSING WORDS.
IMAGINE YOUR HOUSE IS ON FIRE IN
YOUR NEIGHBOR CALLS THE POLICE
BECAUSE YOU WERE YELLING FIRE
TOO LOUD.
THAT IS THE MEDIA WHEN IT COMES
TO MS 13.
CHECK OUT THE RESPONSE TO TRUMP
PULLING UP NORTH GRAND SUMMIT.
>> THE SURPRISE CANCELLATION OF
A PLANNED SUMMIT WITH
CONGENITAL.
>> IS A STUNNING TURNAROUND.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED THE
JUNE SUMMIT.
>> IT IS STUNNING, ISN'T IT?
GREG: IF YOU ARE STUNNED BY THAT
AND THEN YOU'RE SHOCKED EVERY
DAY BY YOUR OWN FEET.
WHERE DID THESE COME FROM?
FACT IS, THIS OCCURRED IN
NEGOTIATIONS AND ALL TRUMP DOES
IS NEGOTIATE.
I'M SURE AT HIS OWN FUNERAL
HE'LL TRY TO CUT A DEAL WITH THE
GRAVEDIGGER.
THE MEDIA CAN ONLY SEE THE BAD
AND TRUMP THEM IN NORTH KOREA IT
COMES IN TWO FLAVORS, MOCK TRUMP
FOR STANDING IN AND -- THEY WANT
IT BOTH WAYS.
NO WONDER AMERICA RATES THE
PRESS ONLY SLIGHTLY HIGHER THAN
GOUT BUT MEDIA ANGER IS DERIVED
FROM A DELUSION THAT THEY CAN'T
SHAKE.
TRUMP IS EVIL AND/OR STUPID BUT
NEVER, EVER WRITE.
THE SOLUTION IS GETTING WORSE.
IF ONLY WE HAD A DELUSION
STRIPPER.
>> A SINGLE PAGE LETTER WITH
WORLDWIDE INDICATION, THE
MEETING IS CANCELED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELS THE
SUMMIT WITH CONGENITAL AND.
>> THIS IS HEADED FOR DISASTER.
>> DONALD TRUMP WON'T STOP UNTIL
HE DESTROYS THE COUNTRY.
>> ARE YOU SURE?
MAYBE IT'S NOT AS BAD AS YOU
ALWAYS THINK.
>> I'M SURE.
THIS PRESIDENT IS WORSE THAN MS
13 AND THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID
ABOUT HITLER.
>> YOU'RE NOT LIVING IN A
REALITY.
YOU NEED THIS DELUSION STRIPPER.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> FOLLOW ME.
>> HIT HIM FELLOWS.
>> THIS PRESIDENT IS AN
AUTHORITARIAN -- [INAUDIBLE]
>> YOU BEEN HIT BY THE DELUSION
STRIPPER.
DO YOU FEEL
DO YOU DEEL
DO YOU DIFL
DO YOU DIFFERENT NOW?
>> NO, [INAUDIBLE]
>> HOW ABOUT NOW?
>> SO COLD.
WHAT IS THAT THING?
>> RETROFITTED GARDEN HOSE THAT
USES LASER TECHNOLOGY TO YOU
DIRECTLY IN THE FACE.
YOU'LL BE STUNNED BY THE
PRECISELY CALIBRATED 30-DEGREE
WATER TO YOUR DELUSIONS OF THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE GRADUALLY
STRIPPED AWAY.
WORKING YET?
>> I CANNOT FILL MY FACE.
>> THAT'S THE HYPOTHERMIA
SETTING IN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT?
>> YOU MEAN THE PRESIDENT THAT
STOOD UP TO IRAN AND NORTH
KOREA?
THANK YOU, DELUSION STRIPPER.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: JUST AN EXCUSE TO SPRAY
WATER ON TOM.
THE SUMMIT
THE SUMMIT SHOULD THAT BOTHER
YOU?
NO, BECAUSE IT IS TRUMP AND HE
IS NOT THESE GUYS.
TRUMP KNOWS WHEN TO LEAVE THE
TABLE, OBAMA, HILLARY, CARRIE
CANNOT EVEN FIND THE TABLE.
IT'S WEIRD SINCE CARRIE IS MADE
FROM A TABLE.
HE'S A WOODEN FELLOW.
MIKE DELAYED CLAPPING.
NORTH KOREA ALREADY WANTS BACK
IN BUT THE MEDIA IS OBSESSED
WITH COLLUSION WHILE DISMISSING
THE OTHER STORY THAT AT LEAST
ONE DUDE WOULD PAY TONS OF MONEY
TO SPRAY
TO SPYAY
TO SPY ON THE TRUNK IN MAINE.
FIRST THEY SAY THERE IS NO SPINE
BUT IF THERE WAS A SPINE THAN IT
IS GOOD AS MINE.
IT'S LIKE A SPY HUG BUT IT'S NOT
SPINE WHICH IS WHY WE CAN'T TELL
YOU THE NAME OF THE SPY SO HE'S
NOT A SPY.
HERE'S A HANDY VIDEO TO FOLLOW
THE TAPE ON ALL OF THIS.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: CAN WATCH THAT FOREVER.
THE MEDIA IS TIED IN KNOTS AS
TRUMP ROLLS ON.
AREAS OF ANNAPOLIS ON FRIDAY.
>> WE ARE RESPECTED AGAIN, I CAN
TELL YOU THAT.
WE ARE RESPECTED AGAIN.
THE BEST WAY TO PREVENT WAR IS
TO BE FULLY PREPARED FOR WAR.
WE ARE WITNESSING THE GREAT
REAWAKENING OF THE AMERICAN
SPIRIT AND OF AMERICAN MIGHT.
WE HAVE REDISCOVERED OUR
IDENTITY, REGAINED HER STRIDE
AND WE ARE PROUD AGAIN.
GREG: DID YOU HEAR THAT?
THAT IS TRUMP SPEAKING NOT TO US
THE BUT THE WORLD.
HOW DO YOU KNOW THIS?
BECAUSE IT PASSES OFF THE PEOPLE
WHO CAN DO IT MEANING THE MEDIA.
TRUMP SAYS AMERICA FIRST AND
RUSSIA GET THAT IN CHINA GETS IT
AND EVERYONE BUT CNN
AND EVERYONE BUT CNN GETS IT.
THE MESSAGE AMERICA IS NO LONGER
THE WORLD'S WELCOME MAT FOR THEM
TO WIPE THEIR SHOES ON.
IF YOU SAY WALK SOFTLY, CARRY A
BIG STICK, TO DO THAT YOU HAVE
TO SHOW THE STICK NOW AND THEN.
TRUMP IS HIJACKED THE BULLHORN.
BEFORE IT WAS ALWAYS HOLLYWOOD
THAT TRANSMITTED OUR VALUES TO
THE WORLD AND SAID WE WERE
GUILTY OF [INAUDIBLE] BUT NOT
ANYMORE.
AMERICA HAS A NEW SPOKESMAN.
IT'S NO LONGER HELLO, WE ARE
AMERICA AND WE ARE SORRY BUT
HELLO, WE ARE AMERICA, DEAL WITH
IT.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
LET US WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE GOT BIN LADEN TO OPEN UP.
[LAUGHTER]
FORMER NAVY SEAL ROB O'NEILL.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
HE IS SO SHARP HE COMES WITH
WARNING LABELS, CHRIS REED.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE PUTS THE CAT IN CAT LADY,
NATIONAL REVIEW REPORTER
CAPTAINS.
[CHEERING AND
KAHEERING AND
KATEERING AND
KATSIRING AND
KATSIMSNG AND
KATSIMS.G AND
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
HIS FAVORITE DESSERT IS BAKED
ALASKA, THE ENTIRE STATE, BAKED
LITERALLY.
FORMER WWE STAR AND MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK, TERRORIST.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: WAS ROB --
>> HE EVEN GOT THEM TO BLOW UP
THEIR NUCLEAR ARSENAL AND THEN
PULLED OUT WHICH IS AWESOME I
THINK.
IT'S NOT HIS FIRST DEAL HE'S
MADE BUT WROTE A BESTSELLER
CALLED THE ART OF THE DEAL NOT
THE ART OF BENGHAZI.
[CROWD BOOS]
[APPLAUSE]
HE SHOWED RIGHT AWAY THAT HE HAS
THE POWER HE CAN PULL OFF AND
KIM JUNG-UN ONES THAT AND I'D BE
WILLING TO BET THAT HIGH-LEVEL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE LOOKING
AT THE BUSINESS END OF AN ANTI-
AIRCRAFT AT THIS POINT.
KIM JUNG-UN ONES THAT BECAUSE HE
LIKES BEING FAMOUS.
GREG: IS NOW ON THE WORLD STAGE
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THAT
BUT THE FACT IS SOMETIMES YOU
BRING PEOPLE ONTO THE STAGE IN
ORDER TO CHANGE THEM, I BELIEVE,
I DON'T KNOW THERE'S A TON MORE
TO IT BUT SIMPLY BACKING AWAY IN
THE LIBERAL MEDIA WAS ALL OVER.
THEY WOULD RATHER NOT HAVE WORLD
PEACE AND TRUMP SUCCEED BUT HIM
PULLING OUT IS THEY CAN WRAP AND
THIS IS HOW REAL NEGOTIATION
WORKS.
GREG: IT SEEMS LIKE THE MEDIA
HAS NEVER BOUGHT A CAR, YOU KNOW
QUESTION.
>> SUITE QUESTION.
GREG: MOVING ON, KAT.
>> I WAS STILL THINKING ABOUT
THE DELUSION STRIPPER WHICH I
REALLY ENJOYED.
I THOUGHT THE DELUSION STRIPPER
WAS A STORMY DANIELS.
[LAUGHTER]
OR A LAWYER THAT GIVES DELUSION
TO STRIPPERS.
GREG: NICE PLAY ON WORDS, MY
FRIEND.
>> I DON'T KNOW I FEEL LIKE WE
SHOULD BE LUCKY THAT TRUMP DOES
NOT USE MS 13 AS THE NICKNAME
FOR MSNBC.
HOW HAS HE NOT FOR THAT YET HOW
HAS HE NOT GONE ON A LONG SPIEL
AND GOT IN TROUBLE?
MY MAIN THOUGHT WAS ON THE
ANIMAL STUFF THEY HAVE TO PICK
THEIR ARGUMENTS AND THEY DON'T
AND THIS WAS A STUPID ONE AND
NOW IT'S AT THE POINT WHERE IN
THE MIDTERMS EVERYONE WILL BE
THE SARAH MCGLOCKLIN SONG OVER
MS 13 HURT VICTIMS AND IN THE
ARMS OF AN ANGEL.
[LAUGHTER]
WE NEED TO HELP THESE ANIMALS.
GREG: AND YOU HAVE TO ADOPT ONE.
ADOPT AN MS 13 GANG MEMBER.
FORTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
>> THEY'RE ALL BLEEDING AND IN
BARBED WIRE AND TRYING TO GET
OVER TRUMP SMALL.
GREG: KAT, ADDRESS ANYTHING FOR
MY MARVELOUS MONOLOGUE.
KAT: OKAY.
I THINK IT MUST BE GREAT TO BE
ONE OF THESE SUPER ANTI- TRUMP
PEOPLE BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
DO ANY THINKING AT ALL BEFORE
YOU DECIDE WHAT SIDE OF
SOMETHING YOU ARE ON.
WHATEVER SIDE TRUMP IS ON YOU
ARE ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE EVEN IF
THE OPPOSITE SIDE IS A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WHO RIP OTHER PEOPLE'S
BODIES APART LIMB FROM LIMB.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT IT.
IF YOU THOUGHT
DON'T LIKE DONALD TRUMP BUT AT
LEAST HE DOESN'T RIP PEOPLE'S
LIMBS OFF SO THAT'S A LITTLE
BETTER.
I BELIEVE THAT ANYBODY BRAIN,
ACTUAL BRAIN, WOULD LEAD TO THAT
CONCLUSION WHICH CAN ONLY LEAD
ME TO BELIEVE THAT BRAINS ARE
NOT BEING USED AT ALL IN THE
SITUATION.
GREG: IT'S IRRATIONALLY BASED
DECISIONS AND ALL EMOTION
DERIVED.
TYRUS, YOU THINK THIS DEAL WITH
NORTH KOREA WILL BE DONE?
TYRUS: YEAH, I THINK IT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE.
I'M AN ENTERTAINMENT ANY KIND OF
OUR --
[LAUGHTER]
AND THERE'S NOTHING WORSE THAN
BEING BROUGHT INTO THE STAGE AND
SAYS WE WILL NOT DO THIS
TONIGHT.
THAT IS BASICALLY WHAT HE DID.
WERE NOT GOING TO GO IF WE GET
THIS AND SAYS, OKAY, WAIT, NO,
NO, I DO THAT TO MY KIDS ALL THE
TIME.
WELL, GO TO BED.
THAT IS BASICALLY WHAT HE DID
AND THAT'S JUST ONE THE ONE
BEING THE BIG BOY IN THE ROOM.
WE HAVE WHAT THEY WANT, THEY ARE
STARTING IN THE SINK IS HURT AND
NO ONE IS WILLING TO CROSS US TO
HELP THEM SMUGGLE IN A LITTLE
CHIP FOR LOVE SQUID FROM SIX
MONTHS TO CHINA IS NOT GETTING
DONE SO THEY NEED TO HAVE THIS
MEETING WITH US AND THE SAD
THING IS IT'S AT ONE POINT WHEN
PEOPLE JUMP ON ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER WOULD LOVE TO SEE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF TRUMP CAME OUT
AND GAVE A SPEECH BASHING HARVEY
WEINSTEIN RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WOULD THEY DO?
WHAT WOULD MORNING JOE BE LIKE?
LAST NIGHT, TRUMP, BACK TO YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: WE HAVE TO GO BUT TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT WHEN YOU DRAW AN
ANALOGY OF PARENTING, TRUMPS
LETTER TO KIM JONG-UN AND WAS A
PERFECT VERSION OF TOUGH LOVE.
IT REMINDED ME OF EXACTLY THE
SAME TONE) TOOK WHEN THEY KICKED
THE 30 -YEAR-OLD OUT AND SAID
YOU HAVE TO GET A JOB AND EARN
MONEY AND SELL YOUR BELONGINGS.
IT'S THE EXACT TONY HAD WITH KIM
JUNG-UN.
THINGS WILL GO WELL IF YOU
LISTEN TO OUR ADVICE.
>> AND HE WAS OVER, METRIC, I
THINK, BUT HE WAS SHOWING THEM
IT WASN'T ME, IT'S YOU.